I'm going to show you how to get this
awesome retro VHS look first we need to
use the shift channels effect take red
from red and turn blue and green off
duplicate that layer and do the same
thing for the green and blue layer
create chromatic aberration by
offsetting one of the layers by 10
pixels create a new adjustment layer and
add a wave warp effect change the wave
warp to square height 10 width 1000
Direction zero speed negative 0.1
pinning all edges duplicate the wave
effect change the height to 5 speed to
negative 0.13 phase 90. add a new
adjustment layer and the curves effect
boost the shadows and drop the
highlights add the Hue and saturation
effect and drop the saturation to
negative 30. now add noise and set the
amount to 15 add the Venetian blinds
transition transition completeness 10
percent Direction 90 width 5. add the
fast box blur radius 3 DP Edge pixels
and the last effect to add is sharpened
set the amount to 275 and there you have
it transform any footage into a rad
retro VHS look
[Music]